حد نعم 230 مهاجرا وصلوا بالفعل لصباح
اليوم الى ميناء تلوم العسكري في جنوب
فرنسا همم علمتني سفينه الانقاذ التابعه
لمنظمه اس او اس ميديتيراني هذه السفينه
ترسو خلفي هنا ان كان بالامكان ان نراها
قليلا على الكاميرا هي ترسو في الميناء
العسكري التابع ل- اا تلوم بعد ما رافقتها
البحريه الفرنسيه هؤلاء المهاجرون يتم
الان التحقق منه هوياتهم يخضعون البعض
منهم يخضع لي العلاج لان هناك كان عدد من
حالات
بينهم مرضى همم بعض هؤلاء
المهاجرين تم اجلاؤهم طبيا قبل ان تصل
السفينه الى الميناء اليوم اربعه اشخاص من
هؤلاء كانوا في حاله حرجه همم
ومعظم المهاجرين علمتنا هذه السفينه همم
اوشن
ايضا من سوريا من اكثر من باكستان من مالي
و من السودان وغينيا بحسم المعلومات
المتوفره لدينا طبعا وزير الداخليه
الفرنسيه جيرالديرمانا كان قد اشار الى ان
هذه السفينه سوف ترسو في او سوف تنقل
هؤلاء المهاجرين الى المياه الدوليه
وبالتالي هؤلاء المهاجرين حتى الان ليسوا
داخل الاراضي الفرنسيه همم حتى يتم عمليات
فحصهم وتقد واجراء مقابلات معهم من قبل
مكتب الهجره وبالتالي معرفه من سوف يسمح
له بالبقاء في فرنسا ومن سوف يتم ترحيله
الى همم دولته الاصليه اا نعم وزير
الداخليه قال ان عمليات الترحيل لي هؤلاء
المهاجرين الذين لا يحققون شروط اللجوء في
فرنسا سوف تتم في غضون 48 ساعه اي هؤلاء
سوف يبقون فيها القاعده العسكريه هنا في
ميناء جنون العسكري لمده 48 ساعه قبل ان
يبد في امرهم همم وفقا للمقابلات التي سوف
يتم اجرائها معهم همم من اجل استقبالهم
حسدت السلطات نحو 600 شخص ما بين عناصر من
الشرطه والفرق الطبيه والاغاثيه كلها
اولياء متواجدون الان داخل السفينه او
داخل نقطه استقبال انشئت مؤقتا لهم لاحقا
سوف يتم نقل من سيتم قبول طلبات لجوءهم في
فرنسا الى منطقه قريبه الى منطقه التخييم
صيفي في احدى المناطق